[Music]
I know a ton of you are not familiar
with my Monday to Monday playlist that I
update every Monday with my voice on my
Spotify based on my thesis that hip-hop
rules the world it's probably a buddy if
you was it thesis hip-hop rules the
world what is super sing to me about
hip-hop is it is now a absolute
fundamental pillar of our culture and it
stayed true to itself it evolved but the
world came to hip-hop hip-hop didn't go
to the world it's flat a 5 right now
throw one thing I'm really good at is
knowing what like normal Americans that
aren't into music will like because I'm
actually Zack I know that's a hit I'm
always right about Monday to Monday
OOP is me I gotta go see you bye okay
everyone out
I want this whole thing don't cut it
because you'll lose too much context for
titling Instagram and try your best I
would say the the only anecdote I know
this perspective you know let's end play
with that okay yeah what is it twenty
eight twenty six twenty four twenty
hello friend or family
I'm Gary Vaynerchuk making this video
for a small select group of people that
John May and I are going to be reaching
out to here in the month of August and
September to get part of our new wine
project
[Music]
running away no whatever the reason I
needed to be half said he just went in
the [ __ ] day there's just a lot of
already committed stuff like a four DS
on the thirteenth year how many are sold
to me for sold to comped quick love you
for answering so quickly
[Music]